yo squad with my soldiers together we  can run this city like a fortune 500  company I'm a solid black successful  Paulo mental  if you want to be keen and you gotta be  willing step to the throne and take that  job  Jana paid he's a millionaire I had my  share a drug deal millionaires are you  like him Gina don't you got you feeling  some cowboy I just like I'm not gonna be  doing this for the rest of my life you  can't be a father a husband what a life  cycle  well um I have to give you that Angel  has had multiple wives I'm married to a  gangster in you're dating one man you're  the boss  I get it you're trying to be a boss I  get quite as strong but we're stronger  without eggs around I want you to get  down with Winston let's make yourself  available that what they have Winston  food  you